hallo und herzlich willkommen heute ist
mittwoch die dreizehnte ausgabe fit aus
dem lokal das nächste workout und wie
bereits gestern angekündigt heute gehen
wir boxen ja es braucht jetzt keiner
fürchten es wird keine blauen augen und
keine gebrochene nasen geben es ist
einfach nur ein workout und wir haben
dafür einen spezialgast einen
leistungssportler den oma saerbeck bei
uns der entsprechend bei der letzten
weltmeisterschaft sechzehnter wo eines
und das ist herausragend die box
leistung für ein österreicher ja dass
die super super sache und am besten ist
er stellt sich ganz kurz selbst vor und
wir lassen seine bilder dann einfach
sprechen
jetzt spielt die oma stelle kurz hallo
erstmalig wo man schon kopf 23 jahre alt
bin leistungssportler und meiner
sportart ist das boxen genau was machst
du uns alternativ für sportarten wie
basketball fußball laufen gehe ich gerne
und ja ansonsten und brooke also es wo
man in bewegung ist ist als
ausgleichssport hat aber ihr müsst euch
vorstellen der oma ist leistungssport
das heißt wer trainiert 10 stand 15
stunden box spezifisch in der woche wo
kommst du ja sogar um die da ist ja
sogar mehrmals sind die spezielle
vorbereitung zu einem wettkampf geht und
bevor man loslegt eine frage noch was
ist der nächste wettkampf der nächste
wird ja das weiß ich noch nicht aber die
quali wieder anstehen ist okay die
qualifikation für olympia glaube ist das
highlight für heuer das wären im
jahresmittel dann irgendwann einmal in
paris glaube ist es dann haben aber wie
gesagt jetzt genug gesprochen fangen wir
einfach mehr an
und was gibt's spezifischer es zum
aufwärmen mich nur springen um auf all
das was ein gibt es spezifische
natürlich nicht sagt dann brauchen wir
das gerne ja jetzt keine sprungs nur zu
hause hat nicht verzagen ja boxer live
cams hier stand laufen könnt ihr erkennt
den hand roman springen es geht darum
dass sie als kreislauf system in schwung
zu bringen und mit schnur springen ist
es natürlich im boxen die klassische
variante
und adorf wer sie jetzt denken kann
normal nur springen ja kaum noch viel
mehr aber das sagen weil ich hatte das
später war er muss sein körper erst
aufwärmen okay aber die spruch na bitte
zur seite wenn man zu mobilisieren gehen
ja das machen die boxer glaube ja oder
ja na bitte dann legen wir los mit
anfang von unten nach oben
beginnen wir beim sprunggelenk rechte
seite wir kreisen wechselt die richtung
wächst man die seite und wieder die
richtung genau der germania gelenk hört
nie gelenk in die lenk vom osten nach
ihnen okay die variante haben wir nicht
so oft macht kniegelenk von außen nach
innen machen wir gleich ein wechsel auch
von innen nach außen und wieder
ausloggen
jetzt wollen wir die hunde schattenboxen
sehen aufwärmen schatten box und coole
variante nicht gebiete einmal
schattenboxen habit schattenboxen geht's
los
die micky ist im militärischen boxen des
gibt's genauso als als sportart ist
übungsleiter das heißt also nicht mehr
ganz artfremd aber wenn man sie den
vergleich zum profi boxer anschaut wie
es der oma ist das sieht man natürlich
muss man fairerweise auch anerkennen die
qualität von büchern training bis jetzt
immer man sicher mehr als 15
also mehr wie 15 jahre spezifisches
boxtraining das muss man natürlich ein
sprechender kennen
okay man will sich immer weiter
hüftgelenk wie schaut es aus wüste
da gehen jan die höchste hüfte kreisen
wie war das bei einer weltmeisterschaft
welche kämpfers da kommt was ist da in
erinnerung blieben die wm-zweite 219 in
russland seinen ersten kampf gegen den
japaner kann richtung wechseln bitte und
eindeutig gewonnen ok nächsten kampf
stand ich gegen den amerikaner im ring
dann habe ich auch gewinnen können und
ja der kampf habe ich leider gegen den
europameister
es biete sich ein bisschen aus lockern
das heißt ich wiederhole erster kampf
japan eindeutig gewannen zweiter kampf
gegen usa eindeutig hut ab dritter kam
vor das gefecht blaues auge davon
gezogen nichts mehr am hut hatte ich
trage mein ist katar vorgezogen split
ist schon bedeutet schiedsrichter schein
entscheidet so also du warst zeit leider
ein bisserl hinten noch aber ich sage
die summe unter dem strich 16
ok ich durchbringen geht's los
jetzt kam ein bisschen tempo aufbauen
beim schnur springen und mein herz für
die frequenz wird wesentlich schneller
[Applaus]
eine art in tempowechseln am apple
langsam absolut okay sehr gut danke
beide schnur springern kleiner das haben
wir schon mal festgestellt wie gehen wir
weiterhin mobilisieren nicky schulte
passt genau zur geiselnahme kreisen
vorwärts das bewegungs tiere natürlich
mit bewegung das heißt er kann sich ganz
locker am stand laufen ganz locker
weiter bewegen so dass der kreislauf
wirklich aktiviert wird dann greifen wir
gerne rückwärts und wenn man gott dabei
seien alle vor und einer zurück richtung
wechseln
und wieder aus locker eine runde
schattenboxen als nächstes aber da kennt
merkel einbauen weil sie so viel größer
bin ich gar nicht oder wie groß bist du
185 ja ja das 110 zentimeter unterschied
aber das war dann gar nicht so
uninteressant
ein schaukampf zum wochen zwischen
kickboxer und boxer oder ich habe ja
nicht schlecht wäre nicht schlecht aber
die füße dafür etwa hätten daran lassen
dass sein weil das wir haben eine starke
waffe
sollten wir das aushalte okay gibt es
spezielle mobilisation übung die du ganz
gern magst einer meiner lieblings
übungen am boden legen ok und mit dem
rechten fuß drüber ja zur linken hand
wechseln genau das kann man zuhause
mitmachen so viel platz im wohnzimmer
sollte gegeben sein rechtes bein
gestreckt zur linken hand und linkes
bein gestreckt zur rechten hand wenn sie
es nicht ganz von der höhe her ausgeht
dass die zehenspitzen die fingerspitzen
berühren nicht so tragisch wichtig ist
dass man da im bereich wirbelsäule und
hüfte schön mobilisieren gerne einmal
nach pro seite
und wieder auf okay wir seien forst mit
den gelenken durch ellbogengelenk fährt
nach rom wie mag tiere zu machen am
besten die unterarme unter anreisen
genauso wichtig richtung wechseln seite
wechseln einmal gleich die linke hand
dazu was ist eine starke hand die linke
oder die rechte die richtige antwort der
zwar schnell gehemmt genau und
handgelenke kreis und greifen wir
zusammen kreis mal richtung wechseln
genau und wechseln erklären auf die
heiße visuelle blick auf die linke seite
wechseln auf die rechte einfach hin und
herwechseln chance dass der oberkörper
schön ruhig bleibt und nach oben und
nach unten schauen und man nach links
und nach rechts kippen und halbkreise
vor der brust
gena mobilisieren haben wir so gut wie
abgeschlossen was nochmals no wir müssen
den körper natürlich auch aktivieren und
da gibt es viele möglichkeiten aber
klassisch militärisch kann man natürlich
kniebeugen liegestützen und so weiter
und so fort machen die linke war es und
was es geht 4 x 7 x hast du mit geschaut
ist das letzte training was
wahrscheinlich selbst beim trainieren
nach ja ich habe selber 347 bedeutet
sieben liegestütz 7 kniebeugen 7c tabs
und sieben mal eine rücken übung geht
schon los
ok fangen wir mit ihm bangen und dank
der wechsel auf liegestütz sieben stück
hat das spezielle bedeutung warum du die
liegestütze nur auf den fingerkuppen
magst ja zur abwertung der finger okay
okay dann gleich wechsel auf sit ups
aber es hat ja prinzipiell gut
balanciert oder ja letzter zeit werden
noch chips verwendet okay dass die hände
noch mehr geschützte marke und dann
gleich ein wechsel in die bauchlage
ok jetzt machen eine bewegungs variante
im spezifischen aufwärmen das heißt die
maschine ab zu am besten einen oder zwei
tennisbälle geht du machst box ok und
schaue mir genau zu was man qualitativ
entsprechend sie vorbereiten muss für
intensives training bitte geht's los
das heißt aus der box position heraus
mit bewegung unterschiedlich den ball
prallen deckung hochnehmen vorschläge
dazu einbauen alle varianten sind
möglich
und immer wieder auch den ball und die
bewegung entsprechend kontrollieren
[Applaus]
tennisball genau denzel mit dem
tennisball sehr gut
ok blogger mehr aus jetzt haben wir mal
gut das aufwärmprogramm abgeschlossen
ist aufgewärmt vorbereitet
hallo sage jetzt mal ein schnelligkeit
ausdauer training was bedeutet es ihr
braucht er weniger boxen wo jetzt und da
wird man das bestätigen über viele
runden lieferungen sind eine der
längsten im olympischen boxen tagung im
olympischen boxen sind drei runden ok
303 runden zu drei minuten glaube ich
genau volle power unter brauche in der
oberen extremität ganz für schnelligkeit
und die man sehr lange zeitraum deswegen
drin jemand diese schlag schnelligkeit
um gegen die ermüdung die dann einsetzt
irgendwann anzukommen dass man wirklich
drei minuten dreimal hintereinander
vollgas durch arbeiten kann
genau das werden wir jetzt herunter
brechen für euch in einer dreierserie
mit grundschlägen die man 30 sekunden
lang machen
die letzten fünf sekunden glaube dass du
es spezialzug dabei neuer dynamische
bewegung was machst du da explosive
liegestütz so schnell wie möglich
explosive liegestütz fünf sekunden lang
die nicht gemacht sprünge dazu und auch
unterschiedliche varianten
das heißt wir beginnen mit 30 sekunden
arbeitszeit durchschlagskraft wie für
handschlag hand unter kombination heraus
ihr zuhause macht fordere gerade hintere
gerade und wenn wir uns natürlich auch
die kombination dazu ja wenig gemacht
dass armut und 30 sekunden ich sage euch
die letzten fünf sekunden für die
dynamik und dann noch einmal 30 sekunden
pause das macht man 3
kurze satzpause und das wiederholen
bäume so haben wir richtig lässiges work
up ansatz bereit wenn wir die
vorschlagen start man in 15 sekunden das
ist jeder geht noch mal im kopf durch
wie schaut die bewegung aus genau
vorbereiten und den 7
in fünf bereit machen wirklich hohes
tempo 21 uhr statt
also für handschlag hand und die
kombination daraus halbzeit 15 sekunden
sind durch um 1 5 sekunden seien die
letzten 5 21 und dynamische liegestütz
gesprungen die kniebeuge aus 30 sekunden
durch
ausschlafen ausland bewegen genau
kreislauf langsam kontrollieren wieder
20 sekunden man den zweite den zweiten
durchgang
diesmal mit aufwärtshaken ja das vordere
aufwärtshaken hintere aufwärtshaken
gesagt zum kopf oder körper kopf kamen
war die jungen körper kopf war aber in
fünf sekunden geht es los
21 uhr los geht's genau und wenn sie es
schafft die nicht geschah das sieht sie
genauso eine variante laufend boxer lauf
mit auswerten
okay noch fünf sekunden dann haben wir
wieder die letzten fünf sekunden übung
21 und übung tempo steigern genau hoher
frequenz hohe frequenz peterlicht die
roma springt mit liegestuhl aus und
wieder durchschnaufen
es ist richtig anstrengend und 30
sekunden belastungs und super lang aber
30 sekunden vergehen total schneider ja
genau so ist es in 15 sekunden dritter
durchgang diesmal mit seit vier tagen
also auch zum kopf oder auch zum körper
fünf sekunden geht es wieder los und die
zweite variante jetzt nicht im stehen
sondern die nici mag das ganze aus der
liegestütz ausgangsstellung das heißt
wir kombinieren ruft kraft mit
schlagkraft mit boxen je nach 20
sekunden sah 50 runden noch übungszeit
21 und die letzten fünf matches und ihr
nicht gefallen das finale drin auch mit
liegestütz sehr gut und zeit aus kurze
pause kurz regenerieren
wie lange hat man beim boxen pause
nachts wahrscheinlich minute eine minute
zwischen den runden genau eine minute
zwischen den runden machen ja und wir
die scans aus lockern ausschüttung genau
schauen dass ein schluck drinks dass der
mond leuchtet wird es geht dann nämlich
leyen die zweite box wurde
ok halbzeit der branche wie bist du zum
boxen gekommen
mein vater und mein vater hat geboxt und
dann war es vorher gegeben die richtung
individualität und immer spaß gemacht
und ja genauso also sport war schon von
anfang an boxen freuen
okay dann haben wir zehn sekunden den
zweiten durchgang für hakan und die
kombination heraus fünf sekunden 21 und
gasgeben buchte sekunden durch und euch
zu hause völlig kniebeuge mit an
strecken das heißt vordere hintere
gerade mit den sprechern der kniebeuge
kombiniert ist super anstrengend fünf
sekunden herunter liegestütze und
gesprungen gesagten dabei jawohl volle
dynamik basis 30 sekunden durchschnaufen
wie ist es so boxberg hat mitmachen was
anderes du lagst noch alles passt sage
okay bereitmachen noch 15 sekunden
jetzt hofft wird genau jetzt game auf
den hof attacken gehabt meinen kopf in
fünf sekunden geht schon wieder los
32 und box
[Musik]
also wenn ihr mir das anschaue
katastrophen werden
ich glaube das ist denkbar unangenehm
wenn man sagen kassiert er unterlag der
wasser endlich geschützt beziehungsweise
horst einfach 30 sekunden nächste übung
hat haken jetzt man aufwärtshaken kommt
jetzt kommt das sagen
die nici tag recht ist wieder voraus der
liegestütz ausgangsstellung super
anstrengend
kombiniert mit rumpf kraft und der oma
boxt ja sagst noch mal vor seitwärts
akten genau bereitmachen noch fünf
sekunden 32 uhr los geht's das
aufspannen rück gespannen
und 5 sekunden von gast gast gast
aber ich sage oh und ausloggen zweite
runde ist vorbei man muss schon
wirkungstreffer gelandet beim gegner
jetzt mehrere hätten genau aber werden
müssen in die dritte runde gehen es
hilft nicht dagegen steht noch endspurt
genau wie lange hast du noch boxen was
schätzt den ja das geht so weit es geht
zu lange 23 23 darüber soll er sicher 29
boxen kannst es gibt manager des 40
box-weltmeister ja vielleicht so kosten
es kommt auch ein will nachfrage was ist
die beste zeit zum anfang an zum boxen
wie heute wird man sein ich würde sagen
als kind egal was magst welche sportart
wenn du es als kind ernst bleibt am
meisten hängen glaube ich und mit der
zeit ist dann um hat mit der weisheit
gehen wir in die dritte und 1 50 uhr in
bereit machen
21 los geht's mit kniebeugen
aber ich bin recht weiß was meisten
gelernt dass man sein leben lang
genau so ist es
da bereit 21 unterstützt ausgesprochene
nicht mitgemacht sich lieber mit herz
und zieht aus 30 sekunden durchschnaufen
der hbw in bewegung bleiben
aber man darf nicht vergessen egal
welches alter so in der wille da ist das
im rang geht an gefehlt so ist es bereit
machen in zehn sekunden aufwärtshaken
zweiter durchgang letzte runde dritte
runde 21
wussten sie konnten halbzeit
bereitmachen 2 1 wechselte hat hohes
tempo beim laufen mit aufwärtshaken 85
sekunden wieder durchschnaufen wir gehen
in die letzten sekunden der dritten
runde hinein bereitet sich vor
20 sekunden geht es los sagt sagen
und jetzt jetzt mal kanns ja beim
schattenboxen oder beim schlägt mit
schlägen in die luft so ausbauen und so
viel spannung aufbauen dass das richtig
anstrengend ist fünf sekunden
bereitmachen 3 2 1 los geht's
halbzeit letzten buchten sekunden ist
tempo lässt der 56
jetzt schon mal kommt fünf sekunden ganz
ganz ganz ganz ganz oder durchschnaufen
hin und hergehen ein und ausatmen wir
regenerieren wir kommen ein bisschen
runter wir warten auf die schiedsrichter
entscheidung quasi wer gewonnen hat
das dauert im boxen ein bisserl da hat
man die zeit zum durchschnaufen bevor
das erste mikro zu einem heute jeder
noch interviewt wird genau also einfach
damit durchschnaufen regenerieren hin
und her gehen tief ein und ausatmen luft
und sauerstoff in den körper hinein
lassen kannst du vorstellen eine profi
box karriere einzuschlagen nein
ok klare antwort klare ansage okay wir
generieren welche geschichten macht ihr
als boxer es gibt die verschiedensten
varianten also meine lieblings variante
ist die gymnasialen schon gymnastik
da fange ich schon ganz trocken die knie
dabei und die arme schwingen
wichtig ist beim regenerieren beim
runterkommen beim entspannen natürlich
da bisschen den druck dann langsam
abbauen
aber es ist schon auch bewegung mit
dabei es ist das regenerationstraining
jetzt nicht nur wo man durchstehen und
entsprechend ausschüttung die arme und
die beine von deutschland bewegung mit
dabei muss den kreislauf langsam wieder
runterfahren und seitlich okay im
wechsel mal live seitwärts und dabei
schön tief ein und aus
gerne auf wechsel
auf die beine ja richtig locker vor und
zurück schwingen
es geht jetzt nicht darum die neue
beweglichkeit rekorde aufzustellen noch
sonst irgendwas sondern es geht einfach
darum den muskeln zu lockern den körper
zu sagen aktive zeit volle belastung ist
durch seite wechseln
genau aus locker markaner ohne weiters
ja ganz entspannt und locker zum aus
locker na logisch nur springen noch ja
die die schnur springen können
die dies weniger gut kennen für dieses
natürlicher intensives körperliches
workout da bitte jetzt laufen am stand
aber die die ganz gut springen können
zum auslaufen eine kleine rung durch nur
springen und wie man beim boxen ist
natürlich die oberen extremität extrem
gefordert der restliche körper
selbstverständlich auch aber trotz die
arme seien sehr sehr stark gefordert ja
und da kann natürlich ja in maine coon
down prozess dann entsprechend die
unterarme und auch die schulter sowieso
denen ja und das schauen wir uns jetzt
nur 23 minuten und dann haben wir
wirklich ein abgerundetes dollar burkert
erledigt ok sportliche zur seite einmal
auf dem tisch setzen bitte nie an
winkeln wir mobilisieren einmal etwas
aus der aus der lendenwirbelsäule heraus
das heißt knie anwinkeln beine geöffnet
und knie links und rechts zum boden
hinunter bewegen da wie gesagt kein
stress jetzt immer mehr
jetzt können wir ganz langsam und lockt
bearbeiten der druck die drei runden
sind vorbei wahlkampf ist zu ende jetzt
regenerieren für nächsten feld
okay weil die beine schließen
geschlossenen die mit winkel die
geschlossenen beinen hin und her aber
schön langsam ohne stress und ich habe
es vorher schon erwähnt militärisch
haben wir ja nicht nur das klassische
boxen was man natürlich trainieren kann
sondern auch das militärische boxen
das unterscheidet sie zum klassischen
boxen mit der einen oder anderen bein
technik nun kniestoß unterscheidet sie
das ganze da gibt es natürlich an lernte
hälfte immer sie anschauen kann wenn man
das technisch lernen möchte oder auch
das buch militärisches boxen darf findet
sie alle informationen drinnen vorsicht
es wirklich so interessiert das sagt
kulas sportschau ist ok er wolle aus
locker bleiben locker sitzen schulter
wie kann man die schuld am besten bis zu
denen genau die übung kenner bereits
übergreifen
schulden sind tief
also nicht die shooter zum kinn hoch
ziehen sollen die schulterblatt und ok
wechsel mal die seite
natürlich ist auch wenn man die faust
ballt ja der unterarm stark belastet das
heißt gehen wir mal in einen knie stand
über und machen wir mal eine den übung
für den unterarm der oma kennt das
seiner praxis dass ich ganz viele genau
das heißt fingerspitzen schauen zum knie
zurück geht es um eine streckung hinein
und versucht somit den unterarm in einer
position zu bringen wo er einen guten
zug stürzen aber so wie bei jedem denen
nicht schmerzhaft mit stechen schmerzen
oder sonstiger sondern einfach nur ein
lockerer zukauf der muskulatur
natürlich gibt es da hat die zweite
variante das entsprechend den handrücken
ablegt das heißt jetzt einmal genau aber
wieder in die strecken gehen und wieder
zurückziehen
lang sind die spannung wieder
herausnehmen stehen wir mal auf und man
merkte der kreislauf fort nach unten
oder die belastung ist jetzt der
herausnehmen noch einmal ganz kurzer
bislang mobilisieren mit ihnen verträge
mit den oberkörper von der linken auf
die rechte seite einfach so genannte
abhandeln lassen
wie gesagt ohne druck ohne zwang ganz
locker zum regenerieren super nicke ich
sage danke sagt danke was hast du den
leuten damit geben für zu hause etwas
machen im lok standorte ins trainieren
dann nicht nachlassen einfach im
training bleiben nicht nachgelassen zu
haben die muskeln schon entweder bei uns
mittrainieren oder selbstständig
trainieren an der frischen luft oder
drinnen
das ist perfekt so genau leute
militärisches boxen oder olympische
boxen boxen ist abgehakt boxen ist
erledigt das heißt workout nummer 13
haben wir geschafft workout nummer 14
ist für die die für im büro sitzen am
arbeitsplatz übungen am arbeitsplatz die
die ja im anzug in meinem büro machen
kann
das heißt morgen wird es körperlich
nicht hochintensiv sondern halb intensiv
mit übungen am arbeitsplatz und
übermorgen steinmeier dann noch mal
richtig aufs gas und games militärisches
training hinein und gehen wir doch noch
mal richtig gas am freitag das was einen
schönen tag wünscht sich noch und wir
sehen uns morgen zur nächsten einheit